I'm gonna put a nerf blaster on a trunk
I want to throw minor facts and hit your
turn out of the air challenge accepted
[Applause]
[Music]
we have an endless nerf war here at the
studio and every morning Jan who's a
deadly nerf warrior ambushes us and
somehow always catches me off guard I
needed to get the upper hand and that's
when I realized air supremacy see I've
been flying drones for years I've gotten
pretty good at it so the way to beat Jan
is to take a nerf blaster and put it on
a drone what started out as a simple
idea turned into the most challenging
build I've ever done and in today's
video I'm gonna take you on that journey
with me as I go through all the
emotional highs and plenty of emotional
lows now I know what you might be
thinking is this even legal well it's
not like we're actually putting a real
gun on a drone or a flamethrower on a
drone instead we're adding a toy the
danger comes from the actual flying
aspect because the drone itself is far
more dangerous than any nerf blaster
around so this is where I tell you to
you know don't do this at home I have
years of experience flying fpv and will
only be flying this thing in a very
controlled environment so like I said
just don't do this so first things first
how did nerf guns actually work in which
one should I use now since we already
have like huge arsenal of Nerf blasters
I found the strife one because an
electric nerf gun makes the most sense
and upon taking apart I realized that
the counter-rotating wheels inside act
exactly like a baseball pitching machine
[Music]
and that's really all I need from the
blaster the shooter riser it's a very
technical term I know
oh hi
you're gonna mount that and a whole
battery case on top of the drone we
don't need any of the guns we don't do
this don't eat it
good luck it's still all in theory I
want to pull off one of those like ax
throws with the nerf axe I want to throw
minor facts and hit your toe and out of
the air a milk and combat okay challenge
accepted you gotta take my drone out
with an ax before I shoot you with it
with the dart a gentleman's duel can't
wait now that my R&D is done I came up
with a general plan a nerf blaster is
basically just three components yeah the
shooter Iser a magazine filled with
darts and some sort of pusher that
wishes the darts into the shooter Iser
and I would move the pusher using a
servo that's attached to the drone
itself that I would control with my
remote controller combine that together
in the most efficient way and put it on
a drone and it should fly and yes I am
mounting it on the top why you might be
asking well last year I made a video
where we put a 360 camera on top of a
drone and the number one question I got
was why didn't I distract the camera
underneath wouldn't that be more stable
well the truth is that's a bit of a
misconception called the pendulum rocket
fallacy which basically says it's gonna
be just as stable above or beneath so
you might as well just make it as
convenient as possible and I don't want
to have the magazine underneath because
it's like how am I gonna land something
I'm gonna land like this and it's gonna
tip over before I can begin actually
figuring out how to attach all this
stuff together I need to figure out how
to power the shooter Iser the blaster
had picked actually uses for double-a
batteries and that's a lot of
unnecessary weight so the drone itself
actually uses a big hefty battery
already that has plenty of energy to
power both the drone and the nerf motors
the only problem is that this runs at a
different voltage than the nerf motors I
solve this by using a voltage regulator
I started by adjusting it to a flat 5
volts
definitely like a regular number but I
wanted to see can I over volt this and
make this more powerful I don't want to
burn out the motors doing okay the short
answer is no because I will burn out the
motors can you smell it I can smelly
smell it I think I ended up settling
around six or seven volts
it's a simple solution I can use the
battery that already powers my drone to
power my nerf motors now this isn't
gonna work if I just strap the stuff
together with hot glue and duct tape I
mean I need a good solution that looks
good and works well and that's where 3d
modeling and 3d printing comes in I
wanted to start with a mag well as a
base so that way I can actually remove
the magazine and put it in a new one
plus all the other components could just
attach directly to it does this thing
fit oh that was so satisfying for all of
this CAD modeling I used a program
called fusion 360 which is an excellent
piece of software and it's also free to
use and the best tutorials for it are
from a YouTube channel called product
design online now it's really fantastic
about this process of 3d modeling and
then 3d printing what you modeled is the
idea of rapid prototyping I'm gonna run
into the cross right there
what I should have known that would
happen PLA is notoriously brittle so I
decided to try printing it in a
different material called TPU which is
notoriously flexible in fact it was
actually a little too flexible so this
this didn't really solve my problem
either but then we got a brand new 3d
printer in the studio from Peru so we
got the i3 mark 3s and what came with it
was this material that I've never used
before called ptg it's basically as
strong as PLA but way more durable and
isn't gonna just shatter like PLA does
so I ended up actually reprinting
everything in pet G because I really
needed that durability this is a flying
drone after all that's what I love about
this you can make mistakes you can
experiment you can see what dozen
doesn't work for instance for the pusher
mechanism I initially designed this like
rack and pinion style thing where it's
like this spins as this goes into linear
motion don't worry about it it would
have worked great except once I actually
got it in my hand it didn't work at all
so I ended up deciding on a design that
was even more simple than that a couple
gears and a paper clip to the pusher so
as this thing spins it's kind of acting
like a piston
so as this spins around it's actually
pushing and then pulling back and
pushing it again so that way I can
actually use my continuously spinning
servo to push the pusher into the darts
this is a big step Nick this is a very
big step I'm very excited I'm ready to
shoot some people all right
I'm gonna put this dial Oh jams the
smugness I'm wearing I think like Icarus
you flew too close to the Sun my friend
you try this one more time ready this is
a good test result yeah he's trying to
create something unnatural out of
something so beautiful and elegant he's
getting close to making this drone do
you hear anything cuz I don't I don't
hear the the propellers of a drone I
don't I don't hear it I don't see it I
don't believe it after iterating dozens
of times on the main assembly I arrived
at a design that was printable in two
parts that I just glued together now I
have a piece that can hold my components
I've already figured out how to power
these components the last thing I need
to do is figure out how to control this
stuff from the ground and in order to do
so I just got to integrate it into the
drone that I actually built for this
project I was using the newbie drone
vivid frame the DJI fpv system for both
the video and radio control and I will
be using this controller to fly the
drone and it has enough programmable
switches to control the nerf blaster so
the idea is that one switch will arm the
shooter Iser and the other switch will
arm the servo which will push the darts
into the shooter Iser a one-two punch as
they say right right and this is where
my biggest hurdles for this entire
project actually began
this project has ballooned in complexity
way more than I anticipated so what's
new in life the problem I'm facing is
that I haven't figured out a way to
actually turn on and turn off a simple
five volt circuit from a switch using my
flight controller it's important to note
the flight controller itself still works
fine okay I just smoked it what I
literally just smoked it we've all
rested down
I don't think I'd ever felt that low
then of course Jan comes in hmm I'm not
surprised
Jan felt victory in that moment and I
felt defeat
[Music]
having a moment
so not only did I have a burned-out
flight controller I still didn't even
have a solution to my problem I was at
my lowest point I'd lost an entire week
but fortunately drone Jesus came
swooping in to turn water into drones
his name is Joshua barbell he's an
amazing youtuber who works on drones for
beginners like you fortunately he was
able to solve my problems now we
actually made a video for his channel
where we go over my problem and his
solution for it
check it out on his channel description
in the link below so with my problem
solved in my new flight controller in
hand I was ready for the real test
non-shooting test first
[Music]
okay I've tested the circuit and it
works it works in my relief firing up
the motors shooting I jammed it jammed
again what
damnit why is getting stuck just when I
thought it was all saw fortunately all I
had to do was basically just increase
the height of this by like three
millimeters the magazine just wasn't
properly sitting at the correct distance
all right it's connected ready turning
on the motors
[Music]
and with that that was kind of my final
electronic hurdle I was able to finally
turn on the motors using a switch and
then using a second switch to activate
the servo to push the darts into the
shooter Iser and then and finally I was
ready to actually show the guys what
[Music]
[Applause]
this is incredibly dangerous no one here
but all right full magnet do you know if
this to go fly
I don't think it's good
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god actually and actually shut the
entire magazine
[Applause]
I'm gonna bring that drawing down it
will find its demise by my hands this is
it this is the real test open combat
against Jan and his axe I'm also
bringing a gun by the way I want you to
actually try as hard as you can I want
you to actually try to hit this out of
the air Jan to the roof
[Music]
for safety I'm not going to be flying
around people except for Jan who is
fully protected and consenting to having
a drone crash into him which isn't gonna
happen but there is a very real chance
that this thing is gonna crash and once
it does it is absolutely gonna break so
we got one shot at this if Jan takes it
out of the air it will break Ren just
admitted to himself what the whole world
has been admitting for years that he is
indeed a failure
[Music]
do Jen good effort no that was such a
good job
care anymore
I just want there on the floor take you
if I had my back
[Music]
I'm sorry man I'm sorry that's good
Oh
man can't be done
not gonna lie I feel so vindicated right
now so vindicated you're a great
scientist and I vow to you it's a friend
god damn am i not proud of you
I'll do this as an actual like node game
in the game with other people the peeps
together I still can't believe just how
well this thing worked this is easily
like the coolest thing I've ever built
now if you want to see more games using
this thing we have a whole gaming
channel called node where I'm sure we're
gonna be flying this thing around in a
nerf game soon oh and also if you're
interested in learning how to start with
fpv or maybe even like 3d printing and
modeling I've put a bunch of links in
the description channels like rotary and
Joshua Bardwell are fantastic for
getting you into these hobbies I highly
recommend them this is an amazing
experience please like and subscribe so
that we can make more of these kind of
videos cuz now I've caught the bug I
want to print some more stuff so if
anyone out there wants to partner with
us with like maybe a laser cutter or CNC
machine I mean I'd love to chat with you
let's see what we can make together oh
and one last thing
[Music]
thanks for watching everyone I'll see
you in the next video woo